here is why zinc is absolutely essential
for male fertility zinc is necessary for
healthy sperm development its absence
can not only reduce sperm count but can
also compromise the sperm's motility or
its ability to move efficiently
furthermore inadequate zinc levels can
lead to abnormal sperm shapes
potentially hindering their capacity to
fertilize an egg adequate zinc levels
are necessary for producing testosterone
the primary male sex hormone which is
vital for normal sperm production zinc
also ensures the proper formation and
quality of DNA in the sperm which is
essential for the health of the future
Offspring zinc plays a pivotal role in
DNA synthesis and repair ensuring the
genetic integrity and quality of sperm
zinc also has antioxidant properties
which protects the sperm from harmful
oxidative damage caused by reactive
oxygen species remember to stay curious
and stay healthy